An einem von sieben orten in unserem sonnensystem finden wir bald
außerirdische davon ist der alien forschers
Estos hat überzeugt warum das so ist und wo genau das sein könnte jetzt im blick zum treppchen wie ist die lage bei den
außerirdischen und wann entdecken wir intelligente aliens herzlich willkommen
Seit 2001 leitet
Schostag dass sie die projekt. Also das projekt bei dem gezielt nach außerirdischen gesucht wird search for extraterrestrial intelligence seti-institut
Heißt das institut also institut für die suche nach außerirdischem leben wti macht das in dem es systematisch
Radiosignale aus dem weltall analysiert 2007 hat es dafür sogar ein eigenes teleskop array aufgebaut sie allen telescope array
benannt nach dem microsoft
Mitbegründer und multimilliardär paul allen der es zu einem großen teil finanziert hat das sind 42 teleskope die
ausschließlich nach aliens suchen die auf exoplaneten weit entfernt von unserem sonnensystem
existieren doch der leiter des instituts
schostag vermutet jetzt einen ganz anderen fundort für das erste
Außerirdische leben das wir entdecken werden er ist davon überzeugt dass wir es hier
Im eigenen sonnensystem finden werden sieben mögliche fundorte nennt er von dort einst der mars 30 meter unter der oberfläche
Könnte es flüssiges wasser geben und damit primitive lebensformen
Genauso könnte es auf dem pluto seien überall, wo es wasser
Geben könne es auch mikroben geben sagt rostek in einem interview mit der website future
Allerdings betonte er dass. Er damit nichts sagt dass es
Plutonia geben würde und drei jupitermonde kommen für ihn auch in frage europa wo unterirdische ozeane
leben bearbeiten könnten ganymed der größte mond
im sonnensystem und kallisto
Wo es wasser und eine atmosphäre gibt und auch zwei
saturnmonde könnten womöglich leben ermöglichen danke an die cassini mission die hier unglaubliche
Forschungsergebnisse geliefert hat titan und enceladus und bei enceladus könnte es besonders einfach sein leben zu finden
dadurch dass der mond mit seinen geysiren wasser in den weltraum schießen braucht man nicht, zu bohren
Sondern es reicht proben
Im auswurf der geysire zu nehmen und zu erde zu fliegen und hier zu analysieren aber schafft sagt glaubt auch an die baldige entdeckung von
Intelligenten aliens er geht davon aus dass wir es in den nächsten 20 jahren finden es gebe
da draußen eine billion
Galaxien jede mit einer billion planeten die leute auf der erde müssten schon sehr speziell sein wenn es da draußen nicht
Intelligentes leben geben würde wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
Ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
Aliens der erste kontakt da geht es darum ob wir nicht schon längst kontakt
zu außerirdischen haben eine absurde vorstellung also bis dann
bleibt dran